with fantastic beasts and where to find
them JK Rowling is taking her magic
across the pond to the good old US of A
in the upcoming movie which is the first
of five will get to explore a whole new
continent
but while Rowling was fleshing out her
wider Wizarding World by unleashing
mythical beasts on 1920s New York fans
were digging deep into the existing
world of Harry Potter
reading between the lines and presenting
fascinating new perspectives on the
stories we know and love while these fan
theories unlikely to make it into Potter
Canon let's not stopped us from digging
through the weirdest and wildest ones
out there so here are five Harry Potter
theories that are genuinely convincing
you
this one's a little out there but winds
major points for melding the real world
with the part of this Reddit user
natural [ __ ] posits that JK Rowling is
actually Rita Skeeter for those who may
not remember skia is the enchantingly
nasty witch slash journalist that is
known for writing Porky's in the daily
profit natural possesses the idea that
skia developed a bad reputation in the
magical community of the years of
writing stories based on bad sources and
half-truths to get away from this she
took refuge among the muggles where she
made ends meet by writing stories under
the name JK Rowling although her work
continues to be based on the Wizarding
World
she takes considerable creative
liberties which is why the magical
powers that be lever to it I mean who's
gonna believe that you can access a
whole different world by running a wall
in Kings Cross station millions of
people that's who anyway we're quite fun
of this theory as it ties back into the
idea that a universe of magic exists but
us muggles just aren't hip to it maybe
JK Rowling is really earth there's kind
of a resemblance Riya is perhaps a
little more pasty though I knew it
find a Sunday
in my opinion best day of the week no
post on Sunday the Dursleys are the
family that Potter fans love to hate
from giving our beloved harried dodgy
haircuts hand-me-down clothes a piddly
cupboard beneath the stairs for a
bedroom and just generally being mean
they were the jerks that made his
formative years hell but what if I told
you that it wasn't necessarily their
fault and that they were under the
influence of some seriously dark magic
like a Horcrux
all right context time a Horcrux is an
object in which a dark wizard has hidden
a fragment of his or her soul for the
nefarious purpose of attaining
immortality
Voldemort split his soul into seven
Horcruxes including Tom Riddle's diary
items belonging to the founders of the
houses of Hogwarts his giant creepy
snake Nagini and of course inside the
Boy Who Lived now the fragment of the
soul inside the Horcrux doesn't just
idly rest inside its new home it's
capable of dangerous magic such as the
ability to influence and possess those
in their close vicinity
Ginny opens the Chamber of Secrets while
under the influence of Riddle's diary
and Ron turns into a right whiny [ __ ]
when he carries Salazar Slytherin's
locket tumblr user graphic nerdy who has
the greatest online handle I've ever
heard of noted that if a Horcrux can
influence and possess those around it
after just a few weeks imagine what it
could get up to after say 10 or 11 years
as Harry is technically a Horcrux he'd
be unwittingly pumping out dark negative
vibes to his immediate family resulting
in their horrible treatment of him over
the years so what I'm supposed to like
the Dursleys now is to feel sorry for
them
it's not gonna happen okay can't make me
these are dark times there is no denying
our world has perhaps faced no greater
threat than it does today have you ever
wondered why the Minister of Magic needs
to keep the Prime Minister informed of
the latest goings-on in the Wizarding
World
maybe it's because a long time ago Magos
actually defeated wizards and the
magical world is secretly governed by
them this is the basis of a theory
created by Stella Rita's 3:55 who know
is that the Ministry of Magic feels more
like a department within a larger
government than its own governing body
and it's kind of weird that there's no
elections to figure out who should leave
the ministry instead someone's just
appointed by some unseen force this
could also explain why there are so few
powerful wizards anymore
there is Dumbledore but his power pales
in comparison to the pure-blooded
Peveril family or Nicolas Flamel who
create the Philosopher's sorry
Sorcerer's Stone
Dumbledore can't do that in fact no one
can do it if lamellas level maybe
muggles killed off the most powerful
wizards pull the Library of Alexandria
on the advance magic and then set up the
ministry to control wizards by doing
this they've essentially placed a muzzle
on the Wizarding World while also
creating the illusion that they are in
charge of their own world this would
also explain why so much of the magical
world is bogged down in antiquated rules
and is so heavily regulated
spells and important artifacts need to
be registered and tracked so the focus
is on enshrining and preserving existing
knowledge instead of developing it
further he also creates a separation
between the two worlds so wizards never
quite grasp the potential of modern
muggle technology which could tip the
balance of control if they did imagine
wizards in cars doing drive-bys with
Uzis and ones they take over the world
overnight and then tweet about it it's a
theory that digs into a time that hasn't
been explored very much in the Harry
Potter books but more than that it has
this really dark compelling undertone I
don't know about you but I'd love to see
a story about a war between muggles and
wizards or one set in the future where a
wizard unravels the muggle conspiracy
I love any kind of fan theory that has a
dedicated website so I'd like to alert
your attention to Draco Malfoy is a
werewolf calm let's review the evidence
that Britney and Nick from Draco Malfoy
is aware of calm have put forward they
point out that throughout the sixth book
there's an ongoing storyline that Draco
is super stressed out and generally a
little bit sickly looking we put it down
to the bad thing that Draco does at the
end of that book but maybe it's actually
because he got bitten by a werewolf
specifically Fenrir Greyback a truly
evil well he wants to contaminate as
many young witches and wizards with his
affliction as possible in particular he
bites the children of witches and
wizards who slight him or Voldemort he
was actually the one who bit Remus Lupin
because his father insulted werewolves
now we know that Lucius Malfoy failed
Voldemort a bunch of times like the tiny
inadvertently allowed one of his
Horcruxes to get destroyed all the time
that he failed to retrieve a crucial
prophecy that Voldemort needed it would
make sense that he would receive
suitable punishment one that was
unspeakably terrible there's some
throwaway references to Draco's new
affliction as well Draco shows someone
his arm and says that Fenrir Greyback is
a close personal friend and he'd hate
for him to have to come pay a visit and
at one point when the Death Eaters
discovered that Lupin and Tonks are
having a baby
Voldemort tells Draco that maybe he can
babysit the Cubs now given that the
Malfoy family are so Sheltie about the
fact that they're pure Bloods it
wouldn't do well to have a well wolf in
the family now would it so this must
explain why they kind of defect away
from the Death Eaters at the end of the
books so with regards to this fan theory
I'm in
it was all a dream there's a theory
amongst Potterheads that harry might not
have been the boy who lived but was in
fact just the boy who lived under the
stairs and went slightly mad which is
not as catchy I'll grant you this theory
states that harry actually imagined the
whole saga driven to insanity from his
aunt and uncle's mistreatment the meat
of this theory comes from harry potter
screenwriter Steve cloves who once
revealed that in the first draft of the
script for Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone that Harry would talk
to his broken toy soldiers and his pet
spider Alistair the whole point of this
was that when Hagrid appeared to have
that long labored conversation with
Harry you wouldn't know if Harry was a
reliable narrator or not and be unsure
if Hagrid was real Rowling actually
responded to this one she said I think
that's a fabulous point and it speaks so
perfectly to the truth of the books I've
heard it suggested to me more than once
that Harry actually did go mad in the
cupboard and that everything that
happened subsequently was some sort of
fantasy life he developed to save
himself it was all a dream is pretty
much the worst ending in any type of
fiction far the ending of I am Legend
that was a straight-up terrible so on
principle I refuse to buy into this fan
theory I do have a mourn the loss of
Alistair the spider I feel like he could
have been a really positive addition to
the cast
well thank you so there we are
five Harry Potter fan ferries that make
me want to reread the books and watch
the movies looking for more clues for
more videos like this subscribe to
GameSpot and we'll see you next week
you